as I pay man boom
once loud noise it's just like screaming
run in and just like children and
teenagers just propelling themselves
down the stairs to get away from where
the explosion was I would bring up the
stairs as I was all running down 40 40
50 people run past me and I wanna just
carnage it was full of beautiful young
girls and it was just tragic feel like
it's my fun was it's been affected even
though it's not we're not going to give
in we are frightened of course we are
but you know more karena
that's what northern people doing
[Music]
Oh first uncertainty muscle
then the show is over the lights are on
and within seconds an explosion rocks
the concert hall just as people start to
head home
[Applause]
organizers try to calm them there's no
problems here just take your time and
keep exiting the building there's no
need but there's confusion and fear and
desperation to get out parents are
waiting outside to pick up their
children unable to move not knowing
what's happened as people run out
paramedics run in which me come on
ponies get out or we go home this week
we now know 22 were killed in the
immediate aftermath people trying to
make sense of it
[Music]
didn't know what got on so everyone was
like trampling over us yeah we just
really confused who's Big Bang smell
smoke and Roma screaming and crying and
just told to command him didn't even
know what was going on we were kind of
hoping it wasn't the worst then it ended
up being the worst sort of thing as I
came out boom one loud noise and then a
gentleman said rad
so we ran it was full of beautiful young
girls and boys and families and it was
still it's just tragic to think that
such a great family evening as now ended
in such horror
[Music]
as dawn broke it all became horribly
clear this was a terrorist attack
targeting children young people families
this attack stands out for its appalling
sickening cowardice deliberately
targeting innocent defenseless children
and young people who should have been
enjoying one of the most memorable
nights of their lives
[Music]
and in the light of day people wanted to
share what had happened at Manchester
Arena trying to grasp the enormity the
horror everything kind of went calm for
about five or six seconds I mean
everyone in the arena was just it was
scary a scary deal and then all of us
and that was it there was pandemonium
everywhere that's all a guy who had
blood on his head and then that's when I
thought it's not a balloon and when we
got up the stairs those people shout and
brew and just run someone's being shaft
everybody's pushing everybody's shoving
the shoes being lost phone's being
dropped I only saw one girl who
literally skimmed the top of the church
she went straight up the stairs cause
she was just so panic to get out and
then some me just heard screaming and
everybody was running from the back
towards the front and and it just it was
just sheer care to people try to get the
balcony it was awful 21 year old Alicia
went to the concert with a friend like
so many others she's haunted I've not
slept away or anything because I just
can't sort of think about it and then as
soon as I stop thinking about it it just
goes back into my mind again just hear
the screams and see the people run in I
just think obviously that I know it
sounds awful but just to be able to get
our ways he was just very looking for
these people and didn't like I'm not in
half as bad position so many other
people we yeah I just I feel really I
just think she don't want help I didn't
know what to do
[Music]
Paul Reid a first aider was just outside
the fray as people fled around him he
ran in as I was going up the stairs
there was all one down 40 40 50 people
run past me and I runner carnage it was
people logging everywhere and I just
started reassuring the man and asked him
his name he said his name was Paul so he
had my name's Paul and I said where you
from
this is Liverpool so I said to him if
you're a blue I'm not helping you if
you're a red I'm gonna help you out any
kind of chocolate cause I'm a red and
his brother we're gonna watch some
European football next season and he's
kind of chuckle again and then an
officer came and says yeah we've got to
get him out of here and the poem on a
maxi stretcher
you know I carried him out I just think
it was what people should do any the
Colin Fitts Conley people he can't leave
people like that he can't leave him you
have to not help them
[Music]
and in the myths of utter shock
desperate and public searches began
among them 15 year-old Olivia Campbell's
family after Devastator we're all
devastated we just feel we're coming to
an end and the car finder and all we
want is people just to keep still carry
on keeping their eyes open for us she
may be wandering the streets probably no
I don't watch it which is injured or or
what so we're just hoping that everybody
will keep their eyes off for a dapping
she's out there somewhere maybe in a
hospital where they identified her or
something like that so that's what we've
got a home Andrea but she still is there
are out there somewhere a day later
their worst fears confirmed 15 year-old
Olivia was among the dead throughout all
this raid after raid after raid as
police investigated a suspected terror
network
[Music]
and among the people of Manchester
disbelief turned to defiance
I want to thank the people of Manchester
even in the minutes after the attack
they opened their doors to strangers and
drove them away from danger
they gave the best possible immediate
response to those who seek to divide us
and it will be that spirit of Manchester
that will prevail and hold us together
[Music]
that spirit so clearly displayed in the
hours after the attack
hundreds opened their doors and offered
rooms I mean we could see people
helpless on the floor and we thought
well the slate now trains have been
canceled so I decided to put on Facebook
a post about offering our flat for a
room with sofas and floor space for
people to stay if they needed it taxi
companies providing free lifts to anyone
who needed them I mean the response was
it was unbelievable from from the
drivers that they just went a lot of
them went on their own accord to go to
go to there and try and pick as many
people as possible I think we've got
duty as a as a company for as people as
well as people for Manchester would you
is at times of crisis everybody needs to
get together and we need to show these
people that at the end of day that we
can't be broken with as one and blood
donor centers flooded with volunteers I
don't personally know anybody it was
even a concert affair but it's just I've
got stuck praying all day I feel like
it's my family that's been affected even
though it's not
this has touched everyone here coming
together in solidarity
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
unifying in grief their message was one
of love in the face of such terror such
hate city like Manchester always
together and you know things eyes don't
happen aloft but when they do people
come together in and really United show
support families from Dallas disappear
we come together and it one supports
everyone is an inclusive city is
fantastic
[Music]
there's other voices of Hope a
collective commitment to stand
side-by-side faith alongside faith this
one individual came and he caused
bloodshed he caused so much grief and
pain in so many hearts but look at what
has happened here this evening we are a
great man Union City and mixed in with
unfathomable loss not just a united
spirit but pride too and a message that
is not who we are this is this is the
place in the northwest of England it's
ace it's the best and the songs that we
sing from the stands from our band set
the whole planet shaking our inventions
and legends there's now we can't make
and so we make brilliant music we make
brilliant bands we make goals that make
Souls leap from seats in the stands and
so this is the place now with kids of
our own some are born here some drawn
here but we all call it home and they've
covered the cobbles but they'll never
defeat all the dreamers and schemers who
still team through these streets because
this is a place that has been through
some hard times but we keep fighting
back with Greater Manchester spirit
northern grits northern wits and Greater
Manchester lyrics and these hard times
again
[Music]
and there's hard times again there's
hard times again in these streets of our
city but we won't take defeat and we
don't want your pity because this is the
place where we stand strong together
with a smile on our face Bank unions
forever because this is the place in our
hearts in our homes because this is the
place that's a part of our bones because
Manchester gives us such strength from
the fact that this is the place we
should give something back always
remember never forget forever Manchester
choose love Manchester thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
our thoughts and prayers are with the
victims and the families and friends of
all those affected Saffy was simply a
beautiful little girl in every aspect of
the world for all these people to
journal means that well to us this 22
deaths the youngest just eight years old
killed in terror and hate these are the
people we should remember each with the
story with a life with a family
my name is Martin I'm 27 and I'm from
Manchester I have 29 year-old Martin het
a Coronation Street superfan I ever have
a cat I've called Emily Bishop
that means the winners are Martin and
Russell he was beloved on the internet
for being larger than life I'm just
happy we made such good friends you know
this is nothing to me he even made his
mother's knitting business go global
through social media and love he's now
the Peter Pan because he never he never
wanted to get to 30 he's 29 30 in a
little while he's never wanted to grow
old or wrinkled so he will always be
young his parents say right now they're
holding on to the memories have not been
crying and sobbing and sort of breaking
down it'll change obviously you know it
hit me at some point well right this
minute I don't feel the need to be upset
and cry when I think of Martin all I can
think of is smiling because I have just
so many fond and really funny memories
material things aren't you can't take it
with you but all that love you leave
behind is just priceless absolutely
priceless I have no feelings of hate
anger at all I'm staying with my
positivity for Martin and that's that's
what I want to hold on to
tributes have been paid to all the
victims fourteen-year-old Nell Jones
popular and always smiling
Martin het described as iconic and
beautiful Marcin and Angelica cliffs a
Polish couple killed waiting to pick up
their daughters lisa Lee's her brother
said will never be forgotten
Kelly Brewster who heroically shielded
her niece Alison how a caring mother 15
year-old Olivia Campbell a delightful
girl John Atkinson a beautiful soul 18
year old Georgina Calendar a girl who
lit up the room eight year old Saffy
Rousseau's warm and kind jane Tweddle
taylor 51 bubbly and kind michelle kiss
a mother of three friends say her family
was her life 14 year old sorrel Lisowski
clever talented creative 17 year old
Chloe Rutherford and her 19 year old
boyfriend Liam curry inseparable and
beautiful inside and out 14 year old
Ailee McLeod vivacious and fun off-duty
police woman Elaine MacGyver have essent
and thoughtful 19 year old Courtney
Boyle described by her mother as her
rock and who died with her stepfather
Philip Tron gorgeous and crazy 50 year
old Wendy fall remembered as a wonderful
woman and 15 year old megan hurley a
sensitive music mad animal lover
[Music]
the nation fell silent for all of them
as thousands gathered in the city centre
and across the UK applause finally
erupted and then a song a remarkable
moment of collective defiance
[Music]
symbolic of this proud northern city we
are do come down here a lot together me
and my daughter but she's too frightened
at command but I said they can't we've
got to stick together
united we stand we've got to do it
together you can't be frightened to do
anything we need to stand together
against this elsewhere another show of
support this time royal with the Queen
paying a surprise visit to the bedside
of young victims wicked target that sort
of thing yeah really awful but hopefully
the mend oh very interesting how
everybody has United everything here
it's been amazing they're just a few of
more than 100 injured in this suicide
attack I have like if you like holes in
the legs and stuff whenever my eye and
compared to the people are like quite
look you really people here saw things
no one ever should escaping with their
lives myself and and we're daughters
friendly away
and the daughter spreads more I will she
don't lead she was one of the ones I've
got gestures of supports are constant
and the community here seems larger by
the minute fifteen year-old Olivia
Campbell remembered in a biking rally
this means the world to us for all these
people to turn off for a little girl
phenomenal absolutely phenomenal
bob'll a stunning young ladder I love
life ooh all she wanted was to the best
and what she could do at another vigil
in another town to young mothers were
mourned we've been posting over the
social media to help to find a mother
and last night the news broke out from
her family that she passed away this is
so sad and for the couple Chloe and Liam
teenagers who wanted to be together
forever
their families say now they are the
picture you see if Chloe is is just to
let that smile on her face all day long
regardless of what time she'll come in
the in the mornings with that snail she
would leave in the evening with that
smile it was a lovely guy it's just the
happiness and the support they gave each
other and the two of them together
forever
[Music]
for the youngest victim eight-year-old
Saffy Rousseau's the grief has spread
far and wide
Saffy was simply a beautiful little girl
and every aspect of the world she was
loved by everyone they wore a kindness
will be remembered fondly Saffy was
quiet and I'm assuming with a creative
flair to a backdrop of terror there's
extraordinary resilience here stuff
anyway you know he's doing things that
they shouldn't be doing I just think I
love with people after quite a lot of
police and go out there because these
people don't belong the streets and they
are Muslims in our religion impossible
then it doesn't easy to kill him for
people and the Manchester worker be a
symbol of industrial heritage now takes
on more poignant significance stay
together
[Music]
you